this man is in high demand
he risks his life driving families out
of an area held by russian forces in
southern ukraine
a local woman calls to say she and her
three children want to be evacuated
such please have been rising since
ukraine launched a major offensive to
retake her son last monday
[Music]
everyone understands a serious fight is
coming to harrison city many people want
to get out even those who didn't a week
ago are now asking and looking for ways
to escape
but leaving is risky too
the only way out by vehicle is on a
ferry over this river because ukrainian
missiles have struck the bridges in a
strategic move to cut off russia's
supply lines the volunteer driver who
asked not to be named even witnessed
some of the attacks
there were five incoming missiles
serious incomings the ground was shaking
smoke was blowing up how to describe it
in one word war hersen is a small city
it's surrounded by ukrainian armed
forces we tried to eliminate the russian
troops from every direction
for those he rescues they're brought to
this refuge center about a hundred miles
north exhausted but safe
one mother says she supports ukraine's
offensive though knows her city could
pay a high price
clips like these on social media offer
snapshots of what could well be a
pivotal battle in this war but ukraine
is giving little away
we've been to a number of different
positions now trying to get close to the
front line and everywhere we go the
response is the same there's just no
access at the moment
one woman in russian firing range showed
us where a rocket struck her home in
recent days
like most in this country she's holding
a russian defeat in her son would
certainly be an important step towards
this goal
debra haynes sky news southern ukraine